-Making her TV debut,
performing her number one hit,
"Numb Little Bug" from her EP,
"Egg in the Backseat,"
please welcome Em Beihold!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I don't feel a single thing ♪
♪ Have the pills done
too much? ♪
♪ Haven't caught up with
my friends in weeks ♪
♪ And now we're outta touch ♪
♪ I've been driving in L.A. ♪
♪ And the world,
it feels too big ♪
♪ Like a floating ball
that's bound to break ♪
♪ Snap my psyche like a twig ♪
♪ And I just wanna see if
you feel the same as me ♪
♪ Do you ever get
a little bit tired of life ♪
♪ Like you're not really happy
but you don't wanna die ♪
♪ Like you're hanging by
a thread but you gotta survive ♪
♪ 'Cause you gotta survive ♪
♪ Like your body's in the room
but you're not really there ♪
♪ Like you have empathy inside
but you don't really care ♪
♪ Like you're fresh outta love
but it's been in the air ♪
♪ Am I past repair? ♪
♪ A little bit tired of tryin'
to care when I don't ♪
♪ A little bit tired of
quick repairs to cope ♪
♪ A little bit tired
of sinkin' ♪
♪ There's water in my boat ♪
♪ I'm barely breathin' ♪
♪ Tryna stay afloat ♪
♪ So I got these
quick repairs to cope ♪
♪ Guess I'm just
broken and broke ♪
♪ The prescription's
on its way ♪
♪ With a name
I can't pronounce ♪
♪ And the dose I gotta take ♪
♪ Boy, I wish
that I could count ♪
♪ 'Cause I just wanna see if
this could make me happy ♪
♪ Do you ever get
a little bit tired of life ♪
♪ Like you're not really happy
but you don't wanna die ♪
♪ Like you're hanging by
a thread but you gotta survive ♪
♪ 'Cause you gotta survive ♪
♪ Like your body's in the room
but you're not really there ♪
♪ Like you have empathy inside
but you don't really care ♪
♪ Like you're fresh outta love
but it's been in the air ♪
♪ Am I past repair ♪
♪ A little bit tired of
tryin' to care when I don't ♪
♪ A little bit tired
of quick repairs to cope ♪
of sinking ♪
♪ There's water in my boat ♪
♪ I'm barely breathin' ♪
♪ Tryna stay afloat ♪
♪ So I got these
quick repairs to cope ♪
♪♪
♪ I got these
quick repairs to cope ♪
♪ Do you ever get
a little bit tired of life ♪
♪ Like you're not really happy
but you don't wanna die ♪
♪ Like a numb little bug
that's gotta survive ♪
♪ That's gotta survive ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]